you will always be able to make money if
your brand is strong a lot of you will
block your own success because you're
fearful of what's going to happen I'm a
big believer in if you don't dream it
you can't become an I promise myself and
my parents when I got some money I would
know what to do with it I would take
care of it mm-hmm now when you line up
trying to take something from me
especially that championship I hate you
Larry you know you just what a
basketball player should be he's an
American retired NBA player who played
point guard for the LA Lakers he won a
championship and an NBA Finals Most
Valuable Player Award in his rookie
season he was rated as the greatest NBA
point guard of all time by ESPN in 2007
he's Magic Johnson and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success number
four is my personal favorite I make sure
to stick around all the way to the end
for some special bonus footage what do I
worry about I worry about brand control
my brand is huge now right and one thing
I fight with every day I want to make
sure I don't dilute the brand
I don't do anything make any major
mistakes because any mistake or hurt
your brand and so those are the things
that keep me up at night just making
sure my brand remains strong and so
that's a good message for all these
young men and women watching your show
it's make sure that your brand is
everything and you will always be able
to make money if your brand is strong
even if you go bankrupt if your brand is
strong you'll be able to still make some
money Donald Trump proof that he bounced
right back look where he is today you
know he went through that phase came
right back because he kept a brand
strong and that's important
when I did my research and starting a
business the most important thing you
have to do and a lot of you in here
someday want to be like Larry and like
mr. Brent is that you have to first stop
being free or fearful a lot of you will
block your own success because you're
fearful of what's going to happen
because the comfort zone is here make a
great living you know my bills are paid
you know everything is great I'm scared
to change so you block your own growth
so you have to now say to yourself hey
once you get the tools once you've done
your homework
then you can start making a move to say
okay hey I can be a businesswoman a
businessman and start my own thing but
you got to believe in yourself first
I'm a big believer in if you don't dream
it you can't be coming I mean look where
you're sitting
you've done a wonderful job and you
remained a good man too with all the
success that you've had in your family
has had and just like myself you had to
dream that you could be something in
life and do something in life and so I
was a big dreamer you know and so my job
was to clean these seven floors between
Friday and Sunday so every time I would
go to the seventh floor was the CEO of
office so I would bust in like I was to
see you I'm dreaming like I'm the CEO
now and then I would kick my feet up on
his desk recline the seat back and I
pretended like I had a cistern out front
and I would hit the intercom but Tony
could you bring me today's paper some
coffee and donuts and so our pretend she
would come into the office and to you
know in one time I'm sitting there
dreaming and he walks in on me and he
said what are you doing I said I when
I'm dreaming like I'm the CEO and who
would ever thought I've been blessed and
Here I am I am the CEO of my own company
and what a blessing and so but I think
back to those moments and those moments
help me to get to where I am today
when I was starting out I've always
wanted to be NBA basketball player but
also a businessman and so this went way
back so even before I even you know was
drafted so I promised myself and my
parents when I got some money I would
know what to do with it I would take
care of it but you a lemonade standing
somewhere yeah yeah back in the day I
was hustling man because you know you I
didn't get money to go to the movie my
parents didn't have that hey so what
you're moving at yes ever out lemonade
stand
I used to shovel snow so I was hoping it
was gonna be a snow storm so I can go
out and shovel people's driveways and
and and so on so I've always hustled my
whole life and I always knew what money
was all about
see the most important thing in business
is you have to know your customer and
then you have to speak to that customer
and then don't try to be everything to
everybody
see we do one thing urban America that's
all I do and that's very very important
and so we have the number one TGI
Fridays in the West restaurant red in
Los Angeles only Fridays they serve
Cristal Don Perry on XO because that's
what my what customer wants haha got to
know your customer
the neck
my mother
I tell you first of all she rubbed off
on us so much because here's a woman
that worked all day then she had to come
and care for all the kids and there were
ten of you and his ten of us so when you
think about six girls at Broadway I get
the pictures and so I got this for my
mother though John and this was the key
I got her smile and giving back to the
world that's what I took for my mother
and that's why I try to help everybody
and that's why I have this smile that I
have because of her but this lesson that
she tried to instill in you very early
about listening yeah I have to assume
that's come back to help you a lot in
life no question about it it really has
because especially when you when you're
in sports and so you have to listen to
your coaches and you have to listen to
your teammates and because they're going
to really affect the outcome of the game
and so I was always one of those players
who listened because of my what my
mother told me and then at the end of
the day also too I listened to other
CEOs and other business people as well
because I don't know it all and don't
pretend that I do
here's Mandy down the middle
I think my high school coach mr. Fox for
teaching me that making your players
better with win championships I remember
when you my senior year and I was after
over 40 points and you said urban we
will never win with you averaging over
40 points you got an average around 2025
and make all the other players better
and you're the first one who started me
off learning that not and I thank you
for that
you think is anybody in the NBA night I
could have played in y'all era
I think the all-star oh yeah yeah I
think that Kobe and LeBron for sure
about Garnett you know uh Garnett what
was his toughness would have been able
to play
I just kissing Doubront driving down the
lane on the old bad boys team Pistons
oh no he would Knicks team he would have
been on the floor no question about it
no question about it I mean he we would
have made all those dudes a little
tougher now Kobe already got that tough
mine attitude so he would have fit right
in but even Kobe would if he came down
that middle you're gonna get slammed on
the floor no question and then the guys
stand over you and look down at you like
what you want to do then you just ask
old things I mean you know but you you
had to understand that you have to have
tough skin because the Pistons may
scottie pippen a better player and you
know Michael Jordan that classic battles
and I love dr. J against labor Philly
against Boston back then but burn our
king you know he might have been the
only player in the Knicks but he gave
everybody hell boy
and so you think about all those
rivalries that we had back in the day
now dudes are friends with each other so
they don't they don't really go ahead
and get the Charles open like please
like please follow me on Twitter yeah no
we hate we hate we hate you you know and
so when we came to the arena you knew we
hated you you we knew you hated us and
we're gonna go at it just like you
taught my Isiah we went at it twice in
the finals so Isaiah drove the lane I
put him on his butt so I'm sorry ami
yeah he came up swinging you you guys
remember he came out swinging at me so I
hit him he hit me and Lam beer so we
start fighting and we end up winning
that series so the next year they beat
us but like we told each other he said
man hey I hate you for these next seven
games
I said hey handle your business cuz you
come down that Lane I'm gonna put you on
your butt and say he did to me but now
today these do
whose man they just friends hanging I'll
speak talking to each other McCoy I wish
I would he talk to somebody man my
opponent and I hated the Celtics too
yeah we all did man DJ DJ lived in LA so
we told GJ before the finals every time
we played the Celtics hey brother you
the enemy and so don't talk to me can't
talk I mean he was cool but that's my
boy but mm-hmm no when you line up
trying to take something from it
especially that championship I hate you
I want you to
reaction
my father worked two jobs his whole life
one was at a jam plan Jim platter of 30
years and then he had a trash hauling
service so he had we had he had his own
truck and we would go door-to-door pick
up people's trash and it was one
situation where it was probably seven
below zero and very cold Saturday
morning and my job was to pick up all
the loose trash and so we it was so cold
that I got everything that I could just
grab throw it on the truck and I ran to
the to the truck because it was just
cold to jump in by the time I got in and
the door shut my father opened it back
up
grabbed me and dragged me through the
snow back to the Barrow to say son you
did a halfway job and if you do this job
in a halfway manner you're going to be a
halfway basketball player you put in
half the time you only put in half the
time as a student and he said you're
supposed to do this job right so I want
you to go get that shovel and I want you
to chop the ice until you can get all
the trash that's trapped in the ice and
put it on the truck and that's that's
what happened and so he taught me how to
be a perfectionist and do everything so
those are
yeah
the rest of your life magic fire
trickling
you
I got up here you do not go into this
hall of fame and win this honor by
yourself Larry you know you just what a
basketball player should be
the biggest reason that I'm here is
because of you making me go to that gym
every summer not only staying for four
hours but I figure I'd better stay for
six because I knew you were there about
five or six years so it was tremendous
playing against you and I'm just happy
and I think God that I got to know you
now there's just Larry Bird the
basketball player but Larry Bird a man
and I appreciate you coming out
Magic Johnson in
five seconds to go
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Zeno asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
could do I'd also love to know which of
Magic Johnson's top 10 rules had the
biggest impact on you and why what
change you're going to make in your
business as a result of watching this
video leave it in the comments and I
will join in the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
is not enough for us just to deliver
anymore we got to over-deliver if you
want to keep all the billions of
customers you have and hundreds and
hundreds of million customers you have
you have to over deliver to them you
know like the G phone it over delivered
so you got to over deliver and so we've
been able to do that with our fund they
turned me down a couple of times
CalSTRS CalPERS and they wanted me to
really come back and understand that if
they gave me this money and and the
reason they're giving it to me first
they turned me down for the reasons of I
didn't have the track record that they
thought I should have and then they said
if it's this business strategy is so
great why isn't somebody else doing it
already and I couldn't answer that so
they said what we're going to do we're
gonna give you 50 million dollars and
we're going cuz I was there for a
hundred and fifty million but they said
we'll give you 50 I said I'm African
America at five dollars I would have
took but and if you deliver upon upon
your promise you can come back and ask
excess the other hundred so I bought a
shopping center for 22 million it was
only about 40 to 50 percent occupied at
that time we brought it up to a hundred
percent occupy we we sold that same
shopping center for forty eight million
dollars
so did I over deliver yes that's a lot
of money they got a lot of return on
their investment so I was able to go
from there took to access the 100
million but also raised my first real
estate fund which took us almost three
years to raise three hundred million
dollars we returned to our partners 30%
on their money they were very happy it's
so how long you think took me to raise
six hundred million
after we returned them 30% on their
money hmm almost less than a year we
raised 600 million we just returned them
about 18 to 20 percent on their money
very happy and then before the market
crash not going to we just raised a
billion dollars in cash and we're ready
to go out and invest this still blows
your way you know that somebody would
want to have your jersey on with your
name want to go in your business and and
frequent that business and want to take
their family to your business this it's
been a humbling experience and sometimes
when hourly on I still do it now I just
go parked a car and watch people go in
and out and and know that you have
affected the community in such a
positive way and and then sometimes I
cry I guess God put me on this earth to
do some some some special things for
other people it's not about me it's
about the community and making it better
and I'm glad I've done